parce qu'en chine ils veulent lutter
contre les mauvais payeurs et pour
lutter contre les mauvais payeurs
le gouvernement a mis en place un
système de ouvrez les guillemets
sonnerie de la honte c'est un sujet du
19/20 nationale regardez c'est assez
différent on en parle juste après c'est
la sonnerie de la honte avec ce message
embarrassant nous les signalons que
votre correspondant est inscrit sur la
liste noire loyer s'il vous plaît exact
est sept personnes à remplir ses
obligations légales les mauvais payeurs
se retrouve dans ce cinéma en haut de la
fiche avec noms adresses et les sommes
d'argent qu'il doit c'est une question
de principe
il faut les dénoncer ces gens là
la liste noire la voici établie par la
cour suprême où figurent les noms de
tous les mauvais payeurs ils sont 13
millions aujourd'hui et pour six chinois
discréditer publiquement il ya aussi des
privations
impossible pour eux de prendre l'avion
pareil pour le train ils ne peuvent pas
non plus acheter d'appartement ou encore
contracté un prêt bancaire c'est une
mise au ban de la société
alors ça ne rigole pas comme vous avez
pu le constater alors en chine donc
toutes ces innovations et que les
identités de 13 millions de mauvais
payeurs sont mises en ligne à la
disposition du public donc si vous avez
affaire à quelqu'un et que vous voulez
vérifier sa solvabilité bas vous tapez
vous avez tout sur un ton et je vois
damian tissu gris langue et qui a l'air
de trouver ça formidable
écoutez je vais pas dire formidable
parce que le cinquième chroniqueur va me
tomber dessus mais c'est vrai que je
trouve ça exceptionnellement bien à ce
que la pression mais dable
exceptionnellement bien là on se trouve
que la chine nous donne là une belle
leçon de transe parallèlement baissé
lorsque vous trouvé formidable
en quoi cette politique un peu
d'humiliation va va aider à la fois
celui qui qui est en détresse financière
en quoi ça va le faire me faire être un
bon payeur
je pense quelque part que la honte nous
pousse à réparer nos erreurs et quelque
part un petit peu d'humiliation parfois
ne fait pas de mal
alors je dis pas que c'est exceptionnel
parce que effectivement derrière je vais
me faire taper mais derrière aussi il
faut savoir qu'il ya un système qui va
vous récompenser si vous payez vos
impôts si vous traversez ouvert parce
que c'est comme ça que ça se passe en
chine en france
si vous restez vous respecter la loi si
vous êtes un bon citoyen vous n'allez
pas avoir de récompense les dames ça
marche pour les usagers est ce que vous
imaginez par exemple que on a dit un
chef d'entreprise qui avait cette
sonnerie notamment avec ce message pour
tous les interlocuteurs avaient quand il
souhaitait le joindre
ce chef d'entreprise si des futurs
marchés l'appel pour pour négocier avec
lui et qu'il tombe là dessus ils vont
dire finalement je n'y vais pas raison
il est déjà élu il est déjà endetté de
revenus encore plus en détail comment
va-t-il sortir la tête de l'eau mais oui
mais vous vous mettez à la place de ces
chefs d'entreprise moi je me mets à la
place du marché qui va appeler qui
peut-être derrière va se faire avoir et
parce que oui bon c'est pas c'est ça le
problème donc il faut peut-être aussi
certains s'interrogeaient sur pourquoi
la personne s'est retrouvée en été c'est
aussi une question qu'on peut arriver à
toulouse magali pas ça leur a dit qu'à
ce moment là dès qu'il ya un mauvais
moment
on a pu encore plus la tête sous l'eau
pour éviter vraiment qu'on puisse la
sortir de je pense que le citoyen
ressortiront grandis c'est vraiment
ces sentiments vous avez le droit damien
cieux pas pressée tu dois pas content
c'est que dans 90% des cas quand tu te
retrouves dans cette situation à savoir
hand et était déjà extrêmement humilié
le regard de la société même toit les
avis des autres tu vois là tu t'es pas
bien tu es malheureux tu le sais pas
comment t'en sortir bien sûr tous y ait
vraiment tu sais que je t'aime mais je
te souhaite pas un jour d'avoir un coup
dur vraiment seul tome parce que
visiblement pour toi voilà c'est
forcément la faute de la personne non un
jour il peut arriver un deuil
il peut arriver une perte d'emploi il
peut arriver quoi que ce soit qui fait
que tu te retrouves dans cette situation
personne ne choisit être en été personne
ne choisit l'aise dans les airs personne
n'est d'accord avec les bd mais
tellement mais pour mettre moi-même déjà
retrouvé dans cette situation il y a
quelques années et c'est bien parce
qu'ils me les mois on parle en
connaissance de cause et c'est là qu'on
se rend compte qu'il est tellement vers
ce petit damien elle est tellement con
mais c'est pas de sa faute il push
marines
non mais c'est un manque d'expérience de
vie et heureusement je suis ravi que tu
soignes avec une petite cuillère en
argent dans la bouche et que papa et
maman soit toujours là pour pouvoir
couvrir ses arrières mais damien tu
n'imagines même ma le sentiment de merde
qu'on peut avoir parce qu'on a
l'impression qu'on vaut plus rien quand
on n'a pas d'argent on ne chante ne
décide pas de ne pas payer x y ou z
c'est juste que tu as pas d'argent frère
tu ne peux rien faire et moi la chine je
vois que la chine à chaque fois
déploient des trésors de créativité pour
faire du name and shame comme ça sur les
gens je trouve ça affreux jusqu'où ils
iront peut-être is here on à les pousser
hors de la ville pour les rassembler
entre les mauvais payeurs et ne plus
jamais les voir c'est honteux c'est
normal à ce dispositif effectivement
mais il y en a plein d'autres
par exemple votre photo dans les dans
les halls de gare d'un garde aéroports
la géolocalisation c'est assez dingue
effectivement on pointe du doigt le
entre guillemets mauvais citoyen et
comme donc il ya des bons et des mauvais
citoyen avec vous êtes vous appréciez
cette répartition juste allé dire noir
ou blanc quoi je pense que ça peut
permettre aussi d'éviter toutes les
escroqueries que dont certains sont
victimes c'est triste à dire
effectivement je me mets à ta place toi
qui a connu cette situation là mais je
me mets aussi à la place des personnes
qui parfois c'est vrai se font escroquer
qui n'ont rien demandé non plus qu'ils
peuvent aussi les mettre dans des
situations embarrassantes médaille et un
problème s'il faut en arriver là on fait
quoi on prive les citoyens de leur
liberté ça c'est le début de la
définition du mot dictature oui et donc
voilà voilà où en est le gouvernement
chinois alors j'incite à fond
les hackers tous ceux qui manient les
nouvelles techniques
pour l'état il faut aller contre ça donc
ils vont y arriver à pirater les
applications et à enlever ce type de
choses qui sont faites par le
gouvernement voir ce que vous en pensez
mais c'est vrai que c'est un vrai sujet
de débat et c'est une vraie
interrogation
alors on parle de la china media pas
qu'en chine à aux états unis par exemple
une condamnation peut vous emmener au
bord de la route avec un panneau et avec
écrit j'ai volé à la banque en elle
parce que je suis et vous fait 20 heures
de travaux on avait des rêves ou marcher
au bord de la route avec ça une sonnerie
de la honte imposé pour ceux qui ne
payent pas leur tête est ce que c'est
une bonne idée où ils nous font très
bien vous dit que c'est une honte à
85/100 surtout la damien vous êtes un
petit peu seul
j'aimais interne aux téléspectateurs
flottant post plateau final sharon est
un peu le plateau